ah ben tiens alors là on a pensé si ce
n'est pas franchement c'est très drôle
ou parce que ils pourraient le voir
regardez jean michel maire est resté
chez lui jean-michel bien sûr fait chez
toi bien joli coucou salut les copains
alors aujourd'hui on est dans les
coulisses du public dire tu elle c'est
incroyable ça s'est déjà fait en france
mais là on sait jamais été fait en
direct et donc là on est en direct avec
un peu vite dit tu es le regarder voilà
des gens qui sont là ils sont chez eux
nine qui est par exemple à montpellier
le t1 montbéliard le pied dans le poitou
à la public donc nationale est en fait
vous montrer comment ça se passe parce
que c'est une toute une organisation de
ouf et à venir je vais vous montrer
comment ça se passe et c'est la salle
c'était lui merci au public alors ça
c'est un succès non bah bravo aux
équipes d'avoir mis en place et c'est
vraiment génial parce qu'il ya plein de
gens qui me disent je peux pas bien à
l'émission et grâce à ce dispositif
j'ai l'impression d'être avec vous sur
le plateau qui du coup vont ils ont
échangé le
concept on a quatre appareils qui
s'appelle des limites l'intérêt de ce
pic est en fête
[Musique]
chez eux on explique dans un écran les
esprits mais via tous les caps que vous
voyez là bas et ça arrive en plateau là
on va faire du coup les tests avec donc
les membres du club de ses soirées avec
ses boutons j'ai pouvoir parler un tout
public donc de chez eux ils sont 32 et
dissiper pouvoir en parler avec eux
salut les copains
est-ce que vous m'entendez série que les
chauffeurs de salle
si on empêche que pourrait faire des
petits coucous faites-moi des coucous
d'aller au laos qui les branchements et
merci d'être placé sur un lit à plaindre
que je connais tout ça fait trop plaisir
alors regarde un petit test de
d'applause non directement polémique est
vraiment mettez vos mains en france
c'est de la caméra alors trois
[Applaudissements]
démissions il y aura un générique
d'accord et moi comme il ya un décalage
de 3 2 3 secondes que vous avez ben je
vais souvent de vous dire un jeu perd un
décompte du fer 5 4 3 et a3 faudra
lancer les appels aux breuleux vous avez
passé très simple là on va imaginer que
le générique de l'émission c'est en tout
cas au public virtuel qui est chez eux
et qu'ils sont fabuleux merci à vous et
on n'a jamais la laponie
oui au référendum le projet mais
seulement quête en laponie avec nous à
l'udpci
merci de ta terre d'avenir mais regardez
regardez y arracher du malade
merci à toutes et si vous aussi vous et
participez au public virtuel franchement
n'hésitez pas vous inscrivez sur 1,8
club plus que la pauvre de les infos sur
le club et je vous attends je vous
attends avec vous m